bonsoir mardi 27 octobre bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 78
voici les titres 40 nouveaux territoires
vont profiter de l'élargissement du
dispositif des sites éducative le
principe mobiliser tous les acteurs de
l'éducation et du périscolaire pour la
réussite des enfants
quatre villes dans les yvelines sont
déjà labellisés depuis 2010 neuf parmi
lesquels chanteloup-les-vignes sa mère
katherine a renoué notre invité la crise
sanitaire du collier 19 s'est muée très
vite en crise économique pour venir en
aide aux commerçants impactés le
département des yvelines va verser une
aide une enveloppe de 2 7 millions
d'euros votés lors de la dernière
assemblée départementale
exemple dans cette édition à montfort
l'amaury et puis la suite c'est de notre
dossier sur le circuit court dans le
département depuis un mois une boutique
a ouvert ses portes à la ferme de
romainville à magny les hameaux
elle y propose des produits issus de
l'activité agricole
mais avant de développer ses titres les
derniers chiffres du chômage dans le
département des yvelines en septembre il
a a diminué pour la catégorie à
c'est-à-dire pour les personnes sans
activité -4 75% dans les yvelines le
département comptait le mois dernier 74
mille deux cent vingt demandeurs
d'emploi dans cette catégorie une
tendance similaire au niveau national où
le chômage est en net recul on l'a
appris aujourd'hui au troisième
trimestre aimer c'est le cas notamment
dans les yvelines les chiffres du
chômage restent bien supérieurs à ceux
d'avant crise on comptait environ dix
mille demandeurs d'emploi en moins dans
le département début mars
[Musique]
début octobre je vous le disais dans les
titres le gouvernement a annoncé la
création de 40 nouvelles cités éducatif
ce label est déjà attribué à 80
territoire dont quatre villes des
yvelines parmi lesquels chanteloup les
vignes avec nous en visio catherine
arnaud bonsoir vous êtes la mer dit jean
paul levy on parle avec vous dans un
instant du projet et qui est lancé dans
votre commune notamment sur ceux sur ce
sujet et sur ce sujet des sites
éducatifs d'une cité éducative qui
s'appelle simone veil dans la commune
d'abord j'accueille michael et demi
d'euros bonsoir bonsoir journalistes de
la rédaction de tv 78 est avec mon
plateau le label d'excellence cité
éducative existe depuis septembre 2019
michael quel est son rôle
trois axes ont été ciblés suite à des
concertations sur le terrain pour aider
les enfants à partir de 3 ans les jeunes
jusqu'à 25 ans tout d'abord l'objectif
est de conforter le rôle de l'école et
la réussite scolaires cela concerne le
climat scolaire la carte scolaire le
renouvellement urbain l'orientation et
le soutien scolaire
deuxièmement l'objectif est d'assurer la
continuité éducative dans le temps a
péri scolaire concrètement cela concerne
par exemple l'ouverture des places de
crèches l'offre éducative personnalisé
de sport de culture ou de loisirs enfin
le dispositif d'ouvrir le champ à des
possibles c'est à dire l'horizon pour
que les enfants puissent se projeter en
dehors de leur quartier
ce dernier objectif implique directement
les établissements culturels les
entreprises le numérique les
déplacements pour résumer elle est cité
éducative ont pour objectif de créer une
alliance éducative et de fédérer tous
les acteurs des quartiers à prioritaire
de la politique de la ville acquis à
quel territoire s'adresse ce dispositif
alors ce label s'adresse en priorité aux
grands quartiers prioritaires en
renouvellement urbain et sans mixité
scolaire 80 sites en métropole et outre
mer ont été désignés dans un premier
temps en 2019 pour aider plus de cinq
cent mille jeunes dans les yvelines le
dispositif concerne quatre villes
mantes-la-jolie avec le quartier du val
fourré chanteloup les vignes avec
l'anneau et feutrée trappe avec la
plaine de nos fait cinq quartiers à des
mureaux et quels sont les moyens mis en
place
alors pour donner au site et éducative
les moyens d'agir le gouvernement va
mobiliser à 100 millions d'euros sur
trois ans de 2020 à 2022
chaque cité éducative disposez au moins
d'une enveloppe de 30 mille euros par an
pour développer leur secteur et on l'a
appris au début du mois 17 millions vont
venir financer 40 nouvelle cité
éducative la liste devrait être annoncée
à début 2000 21 merci michael pour
toutes ces précisions avec catherine
arnaud chanteloup les vignes a donc été
retenu parmi les 80 premières cité
éducative en france on va parler un des
projets lancés dans la commune autour de
cette thématique déjà l'ambition de ce
label on le rappelle c'est promouvoir la
réussite des jeunes on a pu voir de
nombreux dispositifs déjà sur la
réussite scolaire pour éviter l'échec
scolaire est ce que les sites éducatifs
vous le voyez pas comme un un nouveau
dispositif dans ce millefeuille de
dispositifs ou est ce que finalement
pour vous ça apporte vraiment quelque
chose en plus cette possibilité
non non ça rajoute pas une soyons
millefeuille parce que sinon ça ne
serait pas ça ne serait pas
enthousiasmant non la cité éducative
c'est vraiment une nouvelle façon
d'aborder l'enfant de 3 ans à 16 ans
quand à la fin du collège voire plus
lorsqu'on on y consacrons si tout le
temps du lycée du et du tort de
d'ouverture à l'emploi non c'est une
nouvelle façon d'aborder l'enfant pour
qu'en disant une chose c'est que dans
nos quartiers les enfants sont entourés
comme ailleurs de plusieurs adultes qui
sont son éducation et que ces adultes
l'a souvent ne communiquait pas et les
institutions elles mêmes ne communique a
pas l enfant était soit dans les prix
par l'éducation nationale soient pris
par le périscolaire soit pris par le
club de foot soit pris par ses parents
dans l'éducation il n'y avait pas de
logique en tout cas il n'y avait pas un
projet commun le principe de la suite
éducatif c'est vraiment de travailler
tous ensemble avec un projet commun un
projet qui le porte
jusqu'à ce qu'il devienne un adulte en
gros alors que veut dire mettre autour
de la table un enseignant un parent
l'éducateur sportif c'est plusieurs
acteurs l'entreprise locale aussi mettre
tous ces acteurs autour de la table
absolument alors la difficulté c'est
évidemment ce sont des acteurs qui ont
des qui viennent de change complètement
différents qui n'ont pas souvent été
habitués à se parler sauf peut-être
parents professeurs ou parent ou
professeurs monde de l'animation mais là
c'est bien plus large et surtout il faut
porter ce projet pour le porter
longtemps ça oblige
tous les territoires a travaillé dans le
long terme ça c'est important ça oblige
à travailler en voyant bien sûr on peut
mutualiser ce qu'on peut mettre à la
fois en commun et de sport pour porter
l'enfant en le faisant travailler pour
sa réussite et on arrête de travailler
contre l'échec ce qui est complètement
différent pour l'enfant quand on
s'adresse à lui comme ça c'est surtout
le long terme c'est le travail de
persévérance et de travail de proximité
moi je peux vous dire que notre site
éducatif elle avait commencé bien avant
la mobilisation
elle avait commencé en janvier 2019 avec
une équipe qui tous les jeux toutes les
semaines ou tous les quinze jours réunit
l'ensemble des acteurs pour travailler
sur la mutualisation et je peux vous
assurer qu'on a plutôt moins mal passée
la période de confinement avec les
enfants parce qu'il y avait tout ce
savoir faire toutes ces connaissances
les acteurs se connaissent et ils ont pu
s'appuyer les uns sur les autres pour ne
perdre aucun des gamins pendant ce temps
de confinement avec une philosophie
haussier dans votre commune qui on le
rappelle est un laboratoire des
politiques de la ville c'est que
derrière aussi ce projet éducatif
il y a de faire aboutir un projet urbain
c'est savait que cette cité simone veil
qui est qui est en projet à chanteloup
les vignes
oui c'est ça c'est la particularité
c'est aussi la force de ce projet là
c'est que l'ensemble des acteurs dans
son travail à la réussite de tous les
enfants mais travaille aussi à fabriquer
un projet qui va donner le kia des lieux
déjà à nice mais de cahier des charges à
un concours d'architectes les
architectes s'appuyant sûr que ce que
tous les acteurs demandait pour
fabriquer la cité est donc cette cité
simone veil -le elle va petit à petit se
construire en fonction de ce que veulent
l'ensemble des acteurs et la façon dont
yvonne soit rayé ensemble et les projets
qu'ils veulent monter c'est entre autres
le multilinguisme
c'est bien évidemment la culture c'est
chez nous on a on a le un cirque est
implanté donc c'est les arts du cirque
qui sont très utiles aux enfants pour
développer leur corps c'est à la fois de
la culture et du sport et c'est et c'est
l'occasion à tous les acteurs de
travailler mais de fabriquer aussi
l'objet dans lequel ils travailleront
oui puisqu'on rappelle un on précise que
dans cette cité simone veil il y aura un
groupe scolaire un pôle santé un espace
de restauration une bibliothèque un
laboratoire des langues vous en parliez
une maison des parents un collège rénové
c'est finalement conçu on peut le dire
un peu comme un campus c'est ça c'est ça
c'est là
c'est là vraiment la nature du campus
c'est pour ça que c'est une cité
éducative et non pas une cité scolaire
puisque c'est vraiment l'endroit où
l'enfant
c'est par an et plus encore puisque
l'idée c'est que ça soit ouvert dans les
oreilles qui ne sont pas les aurès
coller ça sera ouvert sur la ville donc
c'est l'idée vraiment que lorsqu'on
vient d'être éduqué on s'est en fait
toujours partie de la ville et chacun
des acteurs du territoire peut vous
éduquez parce qu'il a un projet à porter
en commun c'est une conception très
nouvelle mais c'est très enrichissant
pour les acteurs une arrive quelque
chose que des financements de l'état via
juston ce dispositif sont déjà débloqués
pour pour la commune de
chanteloup-les-vignes vous les attendez
encore alors je ne suis jamais prompte à
applaudir trop vite pour le savait mais
l'a officiellement les fonds ont été
débloqués dès fin 2010 9
ils ont été débloqués très correctement
pour 2020 pourquoi je dis très
correctement parce que c'est du
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire c'est des
actions cédées poste nouveau qu'on peut
porter et oui le financement est déjà
prévu pour les trois années à venir
de combien à combien c'est difficile
trois cent mille euros par an elle cède
sur trois ans ce qui permet entre
l'éducation nationale collectivités
associations de pouvoir financer un
certain nombre d'actions nouvelles ou
qui peuvent se développer beaucoup plus
et c'est un projet de site éducative
simone veil un qui doit sortir de terre
je le précise d'ici 2024 merci catherine
arnaud d'avoir été avec nous bonne
soirée merci maire de chanteloup les
vignes dans l'actualité également
l'actualité politique il a été élu de
député de la 11e circonscription des
yvelines en septembre dernier philippe
benassaya précisé hier son dernier
conseil municipal en tant que maire de
la ville de bois d'arcy fauteuil qu'il
occupait depuis 2014
un conseil conclut par des discours et
des applaudissements de la part de la
majorité des arcisien entrée au palais
bourbon l'élu a choisi de quitter son
mandat municipal et en plus de son poste
de maire comme la loi sur le non-cumul
des mandats l'exigent
il reste cependant conseiller
départemental et propos recueillis par
mélanie poker
il m'a semblé que rester au conseil
départemental était beaucoup plus
bénéfique pour notre ville pour le
soutien au projet pour sur le soutien à
l'équipe pour ne pas pénaliser tous les
projets que nous avons dans ce second
mandat
le corps aurait parlé ce serait reste
conseil municipal mais je n'aurais pas
été extrêmement productif en restant
conseil départemental ça me permet de
défendre les projets de bois d'arcy et
de les faire revenir avec des
subventions et j'ai préféré faire passer
l'intérêt général plutôt que mon intérêt
personnel et le successeur de philippe
benassaya sera connue le 7 novembre
prochain c'est le premier maire adjoint
jean philippe lui ce qui sera le
candidat de la majorité philippe
benassaya je vous le disais un qui reste
conseiller départemental l'assemblée des
yvelines se réunissaient justement il ya
quelques jours pour une séance au coeur
des échanges des dispositifs de soutien
en lien avec la crise sanitaire
ce qu'il faut retenir avec nicolas
landry et nicolas kirillovitch une
séance dans un contexte économique et
sanitaire particulier face à cette
situation les conseillers départementaux
ont voté plusieurs mesures pour soutenir
différents pans de l'économie yvelinoise
d'abord l'agriculture des aides
attribuées jusqu'à 23 mille euros aux
exploitations ayant subi une perte du
chiffre d'affaires de 30%
autre secteur accompagné l'automobile
les yvelines ont voté un partenariat
avec le groupe psa pour se porter
acquéreur de terrains appartenant au
constructeur un investissement de 8
millions d'euros pour la collectivité
qui permettra la production de loupé le
moka à terme sont les investissements
faits par psa poissy grâce à l'apport
substantiel du département l'apport
financier substantiel du département
cette voiture n'aurait probablement pas
été montée impossible donc probablement
les trois mille cinq cents ouvriers
ce serait retrouvé en situation fort
délicate
cette séance l'occasion aussi de
récompenser les pompiers des yvelines
mobiliser face à la colite 19
chaque pompier recevra une prime entre
250 et 1000 euros en fonction de leur
présence
autre mesure votée la création de
l'organisme foncier solidaire
c'est vraiment une façon de favoriser
l'accession à la propriété des jeunes
ménages de la classe moyenne
le département est aussi au chevet des
commerces de centre ville
une enveloppe de 2,7 millions d'euros a
été votée pour soutenir plus de 600
commerçants et artisans dans 47 commune
yvelinoise et parmi les dispositifs
voter vous l'entendiez une enveloppe
pour les commerçants locaux afin de
compenser leurs baisses de chiffres
d'affaires en plein contexte de crise
sanitaire est le président du
département est venu à la mi-octobre
justement à la rencontre de boutiques
concernées à montfort l'amaury célia
gars tsongo eléonore sinoquet nicolas
kirillovitch cette boutique située à
montfort l'amaury va pouvoir bénéficier
d'une aide d'urgence dans le cadre du
dispositif départemental pour soutenir
le commerce et l'artisanat une aide
bienvenue pour la gérante qui subit
toujours les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire
c'est compliqué alors il ya toujours un
bon petit rythme
parce que les gens consomment vraiment
locales ici donc ça c'est plutôt bien
maintenant c'est pas pareil qu'avant
c'est pour cela que 634 commerçants et
artisans répartis dans 47 communes vont
pouvoir bénéficier de cette aide
départementale dont le montant total est
de 2,7 millions d'euros elle correspond
au loyer hors charges ou remboursements
d'emprunts immobiliers du par les
commerçants et artisans pour la période
de mars à juin 2020 on va voir avec les
commence à montfort si effectivement les
décisions qu'on a prises sont bonnes
c'est bien d'essayer d'aider mais encore
faut-il être sûr que ça réponde aux
attentes de ceux qui sont concernés
et la réponse pour de nombreux
commerçants s'avère positive comme pour
cette gérante qui a débuté son activité
l'année dernière toute aide était
bienvenue et c'était agréable de sentir
soutenue et concerne enfin que au niveau
commune et plus largement au niveau
région département ils se sentent
concernés par même des petites boutiques
à montfort l'amaury donc annoncé plutôt
cool ce dispositif du département a été
créé en partenariat avec les communes
qui ont recensé au préalable les
établissements touchés et il y avait un
véritable besoin à montfort l'amaury où
une trentaine de dossiers a été retenue
tous ces commerçants la sombre sont
quand même sur sur le fil du rasoir et
l'aide du département est très très
agréablement ressentie par le commerce
local
le plafond de l'aide a été fixé à 5000
euros pour les commerces et services
commerciaux frappé d'un arrêté de
fermeture administrative pendant la
période du confinement suite à présent
de notre dossier de la rédaction sur le
circuit court dans les yvelines les
boutiques qui en font la promotion de
plus en plus la cote
à magny les hameaux la firme de
romainville a ouvert un magasin depuis
un mois maintenant et les habitants
semblent séduits le reportage de cillia
gars tsongo justin brasier et bixente
maria santisteva le garde manger c'est
le nom de ce nouveau magasin de produits
fermiers ouvert il y à un mois à la
ferme de romainville situe à magny les
hameaux
le but étant de diversifier les
activités de la ferme
je suis mené aux agriculteurs issus
d'une famille d'agriculteurs je suis la
cinquième génération à reprendre la
ferme et c'est important pour moi de
faire vivre des agriculteurs de
présenter des produits fermiers donc
c'est pour ça qu'on voulait que ce soit
du circuit court dans ce magasin on peut
retrouver de la viande du miel du vin
des oeufs ou encore du chocolat on est
comblé je trouve il ya tous les produits
elle a pensé à tout on peut faire un
repas complet aux dires des amis il y
aura des fleurs je crois possible c'est
parfait tous les produits ne proviennent
pas forcément à proximité de la ferme
ils sont tous issus d'une activité
agricole la boutique est un relais pour
les producteurs
on ne cherche pas à négocier les prix on
dit aux producteurs vous nous dites à
quel prix on doit vendre votre produit
nous on applique une marge ce qui est
logique et après on vendre à ce prix là
entre guillemets si ça marche pas ce
sera votre faute parce que vous avez été
un peu trop gourmand mais nous on
cherche pas du tout à faire de pression
sur les prix ou quoi que ce soit la
clientèle provient souvent des communes
aux alentours
pour elle c'est une aubaine puisque il
y'avait pas de magasin comme celui là
oui ça manquait et puis surtout des
produits dont on connaît l'origine et
qui sont étiquetés pour se repérer
savoir quels produits achetés une fiche
producteur a été écrite par les gérants
c'est vraiment pour informer le client
de la provenance
et surtout quel type de production
puisque nous on n'aura pas forcément le
temps d'expliquer à tout le monde
voilà le type de produits
comment ces faits d'où ça vient et
surtout qui est derrière ce produit là
et ça permet d'avoir des informations
rapides sur le producteur la boutique
est ouverte du mardi au vendredi de 10h
à 13h et de 16h à 19h et le samedi de
10h à 13h et de 15h à 18h culture et ses
trois courts métrages en compétition
lors d'une soirée à la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux le
16 octobre dernier l'association le
cinoche composé d'étudiants de l'école
d'audiovisuel troisième d'elancourt
organisait son premier festival de
courts métrages
ils ont été réalisés aux smartphones
tous par des novices en cinéma dix-huit
personnes en tout ont participé à des
ateliers proposés par l'association en
début d'année l'objectif favoriser
l'accès au cinéma de l'interview
collectées par justine brasier c'était
dix séances de deux heures pour
apprendre à tourner un court-métrage de
a à z du scénario à la projection on
commence par trouver le scénario via des
jeux d'improvisation des tables rondes
et débats comme ça on peut écrire une
trame et après on passe au tournage et
alors là ils sont six à la fois acteurs
et actrices du coup et quand ils ne
jouent pas ils sont derrière la caméra
pour faire les cadrages apprendre les
règles élémentaires du cinéma moi je
faisais ce jour là
si raconte une histoire dramatique avec
une fille qui perd son ami j'ai adoré
l'histoire dramatique et surtout le
début j'ai a duré une ya une scène du
début que j'ai adoré c'était vraiment
whaou c'était superbe
l'ensemble de ces courts métrages à
retrouver prochainement sur la page
youtube de l'association le cinoche et
l'un de ses films justement charme est
pas si charmant a été présenté dans le
cadre de cette soirée il a reçu le prix
coup de coeur du public présentation
avec justin brasier charmer pas ces
charmants un court métrage réalisé par
une équipe de six cinéastes en herbe un
projet de 20 minutes qui fait écho à
l'actualité
on était un groupe avec des jeunes et
des moins jeunes donc voilà ça nous a
permis de mettre en place une bonne
dynamique et c'est un court métrage sur
ce qui se passe avec des méchants virus
qui arrive à un moment donné et ce qui
se passe quand on est une petite
collectivité
je suis en tête de radio
le projet résulte d'un atelier organisé
sur plusieurs jours par l'association le
cinoche
il permettait d'apprendre les techniques
du cinéma sur smartphone c'est un
atelier sur ces quatre jours continue
donc tous les jours on est venu pour
travailler avec thomas et enzo qui nous
ont bien coachés et puis mes camarades
de tournage grâce à cette expérience les
comédiens amateurs ont pu découvrir
l'envers du décor hélène nous raconte
une anecdote de tournage
tout d'un coup on s'est mis entendre un
marteau piqueur juste à côté
et c'était la boucherie à côté qui
venait de refaire entièrement le magasin
donc là on a eu un peu peur et puis on a
quand même pu arriver à travailler avec
eux quand travaillez pas en faisait nos
tournage donc voila un petit peu les
aléas des fois de du cinéma l'équipe a
présenté son film au festival de courts
métrages sur smartphone organisé par le
cinoche à magny les hameaux charmer pas
ces charmants a reçu le prix coup de
coeur du public
cette information avant de vous laisser
le salon du livre d'elancourt est
reportée à mai 2021 en raison de la
crise sanitaire qui s'amplifie à la
quatrième édition de l'événement devait
se tenir le 29 novembre prochain à la
commanderie 40 auteurs et journalistes
étaient attendus le même thème sera
proposé au printemps prochain de tintin
au grand reporter du 21e siècle et dans
un instant ne manquez pas un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture pour faire le tour
de l'actualité culturelle dans le
département voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]